Hello, ich begrüße euch zu einem neuen Cheesecake Rezept!
Ich bin ja ein absoluter Cheesecake Fanatiker und ich kann sagen unser
liebster Cheesecake ist der San Sebastian Cheesecake. Punkt!
Ich mache jetzt hier schlechte Werbung für dieses Rezept
aber auf Platz Zwei kommt der New York Cheesecake!
Und deshalb kommt heute auch eine Art New York Cheesecake, den ich aber mit Erdbeeren verfeinere
und der ist auch mega lecker!
Und ich habe jetzt hier schon mal Vorarbeit geleistet. Ich habe Butterkekse fein gemixt
und da kommt jetzt etwas Butter dazu, die ich vorab in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen habe.
Der Keksboden kommt dann in eine 20cm Springform, einfach schön gleichmäßig verteilen
und flach andrücken und der kommt jetzt ganz kurz zur Seite.
Wir machen jetzt nämlich die Cheesecake Masse.
Das könnt ihr entweder mit einem Schneebesen oder ganz einfach die Küchenmaschine nehmen.
ganz wie ihr mögt. Und die ganz genauen Mengenangaben,
die stehen immer hier unten in der Infobox. Da müsst ihr neben dem Titel einfach den Pfeil anklicken,
dann öffnet sie sich. so und jetzt habe ich hier Doppelrahmfrischkäse, der gehört immer dazu
zum amerikanischen Cheesecake, ganz ganz wichtig! Dann habe ich hier Schmand,
ihr könntet auch Crème fraîche nehmen, das ist komplett euch überlassen! Ich hab jetzt hier Schmand da gehabt.
Ansonsten Eier, Zucker, Vanilleextrakt und Zitronenschalenabrieb.
So und zum Schluss kommt dann noch ein bisschen Mehl dazu,
einfach damit die Masse später besser bindet und dann nur ganz kurz verrühren
bis sich alle Zutaten miteinander verbunden haben.
So die Cheesecake-Masse habe ich dann ganz einfach eingefüllt und noch ein bisschen glatt gestrichen
und jetzt wandert sie auch schon in den Backofen bei 150° C Ober- und Unterhitze.
Ganz wichtig: Heizt den Ofen immer vor und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder!
So ihr Lieben, mein Käsekuchen ist fertig gebacken und jetzt muss er nur noch auskühlen
(H: Und er hat keine Risse!)
Ja, der hat keine Risse, ich hab immer einen Trick: ich nehme immer einen Holzstiel
- oder meinem Fall Silikonkochlöffel, irgendwas hitzebeständiges -
und klemme das zwischen die Ofentür. Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich was zugeben:
(H: Aber nachdem es fertig gebacken ist!)
Nachdem es fertig gebacken ist natürlich!
Lasst den dann erstmal da auskühlen, jetzt ist er noch ganz leicht lauwarm und gleich kommt er für
mindestens 4h in den Kühlschrank.
Aber ich muss sagen es kommt auch immer darauf an, was für eine Temperatur dann hier im Raum ist.
Manchmal mache ich den Trick und habe trotzdem einen Riss, deswegen dürft ihr nicht traurig sein
wenn es dann doch nicht klappt. Aber ist auch gar nicht schlimm, denn lieber Hamza?
(H: Auf den Geschmack kommt's an!)
Erstens das und wir machen sowieso
noch ein Erdbeerpüree obendrauf, das heißt man würde das eh nicht erkennen.
Ich hab jetzt hier Erdbeeren in meinem Topf, geb da ein bisschen Wasser dazu
- der Herd ist noch nicht eingeschaltet - erstmal ein bisschen Wasser mit dazu.
Ich schreibe euch hier auch alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben in die Infobox
und jetzt schnapp ich mir meinen Pürierstab und pürier die einmal durch.
Als nächstes Zucker und Speisestärke dazugeben, schön klümpchenfrei verrühren
und dann erst den Herd einschalten. sobald das Ganze anfängt zu kochen 2min lang köcheln lassen
und dann habt ihr so eine relativ dicke Soße und das ist später unser Topping.
Das habe ich jetzt ca 10min lang ausdampfen lassen damit jetzt die Erdbeeren,
die ich in kleine Stücke geschnitten habe, nicht in die heiße Soße kommen.
Einfach rein geben und dann mit dem Cheesecake zusammen servieren.
Unseren Taste Test habt ihr auf Instagram gesehen.
Falls ihr uns dort noch nicht folgt, dann ganz schnell nachholen, schreibe ich euch in die Infobox.
Ich schreib euch auch Hamzas Account rein weil Hamza du machst meistens den Taste Test!
(H: Ich mach immer den Taste Test!)
Und immer gnadenlos ehrlich. Gnadenlos!
Deshalb folgt uns unbedingt! Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken
Unbedingt ausprobieren, ich liebe ja Cheesecakes!
Ich mache euch mal eine Cheesecake Playlist von mir dann habt ihr alle Cheesecakes auf einen Blick!
Und schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare, welche Varianten ihr noch sehen möchtet.
Und dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten Mal hier auf meinem Kanal!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!